hello and welcome to insight Germany my
guest today is a musician who's
originally from Canada but came to live
in Oldenburg in the north of Germany way
back in 1983 he's now been living in
Germany for over 30 years
Martin Gallup is a singer-songwriter and
in the course of this interview he will
be playing live and exclusively for this
program a song or two from his brand-new
album which is called most beautiful
song welcome to the show they only
rather I have to ask you straight away
about your music but I won't ask you so
much but about this contraption that we
have here that is a part of your
performance a true thing of beauty don't
I mean I recognize the old gramophone
which is very beautiful isn't I know you
again that comes in the report about you
later
okay tell us about that this thing that
looks sort of like garden hose and is in
a way is actually also what you would
call in German site Slough which is time
hose in English time huh time hold the
problem is I made this record which is
here down beside the gramophone and it's
a brilliant record beautifully
beautifully produced by myself and there
are a lot of songs on it that have a
sort of nostalgic kind of feel to them
and I've been thinking how can i evoke
that nostalgic atmosphere that's on the
record when I perform the songs live and
so I you know study so it has a
particular sound which will we'll come
to exactly it has a particular sound and
it's it's sort of my own invention
together with the help of a man from a
hardware store and yeah well I think I'm
gonna spoil it all but we're gonna see
the hardware store a little bit hardly
yes you're from Toronto is it is it a
musical this is Toronto in Canada I
should say from a musical family at all
I think you could say that definitely
most
father was a you know an amateur
musician he was involved in a lot of
musical productions of old Gilbert and
Sullivan musicals that he loved and he
played a lot of Records
when I was was young and played the
piano and I've got two brothers who also
went into music professionally Britain
they said no this moment I think this is
you on the left with your daddies I
should have my glasses but yeah and you
said we say Toronto Canada this doesn't
look like Toronto that that will not be
trottle that must be England it
absolutely all of you I was gonna say
that's go big nents so what's that
connection well my parents are British
aha my father was born in London and my
parents both met in Oxford uh-huh and so
you know we were often back in England
when I was young and they emigrated to
and they they emigrated to Canada in the
50s and individually actually they they
weren't a couple question but they knew
each other and then they kind of were
like you know fellow expatriates who
ended up married and there's another
place you says I love this I love that
this is this this is dangerous it this
is a dangerous gang on the street
Toronto in the 1960s yeah well I see the
car in the background yeah absolutely
and that the bad man thing we were
trouble indeed and you know when I see
that picture I think about how Batman
you know was a series that was running
it wasn't rerunning at the time it was
actually a an actual series that ran
once a week I think on Tuesdays or
whatever and when Batman came on around
seven o'clock in the evening the streets
that were otherwise filled with children
were completely empty now back in those
days you go to mate on streets you know
oh you did and this sorry one more
because I just loved some of the photos
you sent him and this is just this is
biographers yeah I think we should
explain that this is not some strange
sect you know this was you underneath
Niagara Falls you all through with your
brothers
yeah all my siblings my sister at the
very back there in front of my father
and then my my two other brothers were
in in you know in age in order of age
mm-hmm and and this this was at Niagara
Falls and I want to know how did you get
into music well your family was musical
sure my family was musical and I we know
there was a piano in the house and there
was a guitar my father had a guitar and
he had it locked away in his closet I
used to have to ask for permission to be
able to play the guitar which was it
psychologically probably a good thing so
I it was something special and sacred
that I would have to ask my father can I
play the guitar and he would take it out
of the closet and give it to me and I
would bash away on Beatles song of a
Beatles song book with you know those
chord diagrams and yeah that's how I if
I could mention one name - I mean what
might have been inspirational musically
Mindy Mindy actually I should say fairly
the names have been changed to protect
protect innocence by one by one letter
in case Mindy's out there this is I mean
we must say this is I think you were 12
yeah - 11 or 12 I was in grade seven I
mean we were it was big love we were
together for like eight or nine months
which was a long time but you know it
was like a whole school season yeah and
she dumped me at the end of grade seven
later it was explained to me that high
school was coming up and she would be
going into grade nine soon and you know
she had to kind of pave the way for for
the big boys that would probably be
making advances and I actually really
was pretty heart broke for a couple of
years there and that definitely opened
up you know the possibility to having
you know a little what do you wrote a
song I did I wrote was the first I first
composition I hope you're not gonna ask
me to sing it today
oh did indeed yes I wrote my first
heartbreak song from and did this help
did the music help I guess it probably
did yeah yeah I've had the same
experience but we're not talking about
me I just didn't know but I'm now going
to be a very father-like figure enough
to pick up your guitar it would take the
guitar out of the out of the case I'll
unlock the case yeah as a guitar right I
know you're gonna give us a little
snippet of something yeah this is one's
for you Robin
not just for everybody out there I know
you're thinking I'm no good guess you
should there been some drinking yeah now
I recall but I wasn't me that was Oh
there is a sweet side to the two and I
really want to show it to you so won't
it give me one more chance can I have
another chance I could use a second
chance to make a good first impression
wonderful thank you
that's an impression of their first
impression the last song on Martin's
album will be giving away a couple of
copies later in the program but now
let's find out more about him and that
gramophone as he showed us around his
neighborhood here in Berlin
singer-songwriter Martin Gallup has
lived in Berlin for six years one of his
favorite spots is on the banks of the
river spree
this is the sound of a city train
pulling into the station brakes
directly behind me here we have the
windows of my studio where I recorded my
last record most beautiful song the
records I'm actually finished and I'm
out of that studio now unfortunately but
it had an absolutely spectacular view of
the spray here we're right at the banks
of the river and the s-bahn and the
trains going by wonderful Martin first
hopped on the train and hit the road at
age 20 in Germany he's recorded four
albums you know how I'm always losing my
way losing my mind even a trail from the
hills he's also in demand as a producer
and sideman performing with the lights
of German rock legend known Lindenberg
and he produced in wrote songs for
German pop icon Annette Louise on with
whom he was also romantically linked for
a while he lives in the Verano Keats
neighborhood in multicultural Kreuzberg
he often finds things he can use in his
shows in a cornered junk shop item
walking down the street just like this
and bang there's a gramophone sitting
right outside here and the guy came out
and was demonstrating it to me and there
was this gamma phone music playing out
into the street okay magic all that
moment and right in that same moment
this this other guy walks by and stops
and kind of whispers in my ear a man
you're looking for gramophones like he
was selling drugs or something
I said yeah I got gramophones man I got
really good gramophones
Martin used one to create a unique
analog effects unit the highlight of
Martin's recent homecoming gig interact
with new partner a Baudette ramadani and
the special guest appearance of the
couple's newborn baby
bottom bottom
but uh
and here he is live in the studio with
us only in Berlin
I got grandma that was a world premiere
I think for your daughter who's yeah you
you got a trainer making me all
sentimental here in the studio and he
slept she was asleep that night yeah I
get it bit a trick how much mustn't
sleep through our fathers console Oh in
this case I think it's just as well yeah
you've actually I mean you've actually
that that's daughter very very young but
you've got a 22 year old daughter I do
I do indeed yeah who I who I raised in
Oldenburg
which is she was kind of the real reason
why I stayed in Germany for so long and
she is now a year I am completely
entrenched in German culture and German
life and she's gonna move back to Canada
where well not moved back but it's moved
to Canada where I grew up she's studying
in Toronto you say entrenched and I'm
not including your lyrics here because
you lose you write in English but your
lyrics must obviously be your
experiences here but your music to me
I've heard the whole album and then your
music sounds very North American mm-hmm
and yet you have German musicians on the
album so so our German musical
influences do you think I think probably
I mean when I was a little younger I was
probably more influenced by German
trends like I was actually trying for a
while to make eurodance music and all
kinds of things like that but I think
the longer I was away from home the more
I started to sort of look for my own
musical roots and yeah you know that
idea of that people who inhabit colonies
like migrants from France who go to
Canada or that expatriates so to speak
are are often more we become more
Canadian I become more British exactly
when you
abroad are you for you find more to that
so perhaps that's it so what were your
first impressions of Germany growing up
I mean and I love Germany when it when I
came here and before you came here
before you came here I've just include
this picture with it because here you
are in Canada I noticed that there's a
that's very definitely a German car we
all know yeah
the Volkswagen Beetle yeah you know and
yeah what what did you think of Germany
before you came you know I have to say I
the only really the only thing I really
knew about Germany was through a
television show called Hogan's Heroes
I don't know if you know Hogan's is an
American television show about prisoners
of war in Germany during the Second
World War and it you know it just makes
the Germans look like complete idiots
and that was sort of all I really knew
about Germany which is pretty poor yeah
yeah I mean okay
so that's that but you actually you as I
mentioned beginning you've actually been
here for over half your life I know and
really pretty much all of my adult life
it's so tell us why did you first of all
come here well really actually a friend
of mine told me when I was about 19 and
not a very happy camper at the time he
said you know Mike I was just in Germany
you should you should really go there
one they really love Neil Young because
I was sort of into this whole folk music
thing at the time born down the road
from who was born down the road from me
and to the girls over there actually I
decided I better go and check that out
and so what happened you came to well
why Oldenburg nothing against Oldenburg
knows but people come to Berlin they go
to Hamburg they go to Munich that's
there is another and very important
figure in all of this was a man called
Behrendt who's from Oldenburg who I met
on the west coast of Canada when I was
doing a street music
it's a tour with a friend of mine we
traveled from Toronto right out to the
west coast just by singing songs on the
street and we were you know we were
young and crazy and our heads were full
of psychedelic drugs and we met this man
Behrendt who'd been travelling himself
for about two or three years and I think
he'd spent like a year in India and he
he was all you know spiritual eyes by
his his travels and was full of sort of
dualistic wisdom and I'm from Oldenburg
and from Oldenburg and he was you know
spouting off all of this sort of guru
and wisdom to us and I was completely
swept away by by his words and he had
this big beard and was quite a quite a
mystical looking figure and I more or
less sort of followed him like a few
months later at 2:00 to Oldenburg to to
get more of that and when I actually
arrived he was really in a very
different state he'd been back in his
home again in this little town Oldenburg
he'd fallen unhappily in love with with
somebody there and he was terribly
caught up in whether he should phone her
or not
so our conversations weren't quite as
lofty as quite the Guru man and a friend
and a real catalyst in their life but I
believe also that we can return to the
female in that I think but I believe it
was a very special kiss in all he took
me to a bar my first a second night in
town and we were having a conversation
and there was a woman across the room
who seemed to be looking at me and I was
looking at her and we were you know
flirting with our eyes for for pretty
much the whole evening and then she got
up to leave she put a coat on and came
over to me and just planted a big kiss
right on my lips oh wow yeah and this
was really of a love story with I don't
know vampire well actually you know in
the end we we we didn't conversely just
left immediately but we ran into each
other again a few weeks later it being a
very small town and and yeah I mean
obviously that was sort of like you know
quite a welcome
after this country I knew you I know you
worked then in a in a theater group it
was this in German it was it was an
English group we used some German
language as well we had a couple of guys
who were German in the group again
another thing about Oldenburg a few
weeks later I met a man who also had a
girlfriend in in old America he was from
California Gary Edwards and we got
talking at a party and he was saying oh
well we're looking for a guy who could
travel with us and do lights and sound
for our for a little theatre couple sure
it's a trained person I'm already
trained into anything actually you know
what I are trained they're qualified
yeah a candidate have no post-secondary
education you know I was my parents are
very academic and I somehow seemed to
want to rebel against that I don't know
I'm sorry dad and you moved to Berlin
about six years ago if I got that right
now I know that's about right yeah and
you've been inaudible which is in the
north of Arlen's in the north ish I mean
it's in the east side and your favorite
part of the the country you put in our
questionnaire which s in there who's on
the Baltic Sea the DARS Peninsula I mean
do you particularly prefer northern
parts I don't know if that's really true
no I love South Germany too and you know
southern Europe and mountains and
everything but this particular landscape
on the Dara's yeah there's something
about it I always have very very strange
dreams they're nightmares too sometimes
it just opens up there well it's a bit
of an artist colony as it is indeed
right is that what's the name Aran's
hope yeah well we're gonna yeah it's a
look that's a Dharan ensure Peninsula
which is right up in the north east of
Germany on the Baltic Sea and it's
Martin gallops insider tip should you
come to this country
sixty kilometers of beach line the fish
lenders peninsula its widest near the
town of Clerval in the north after a
winter of Sun starvation many brave the
relatively cool spring temperatures to
come here and fill up on light after the
decline of seafaring in the mid 19th
century the local tourism industry
blossomed many say this is one of the
Baltics most beautiful beaches the town
centre is reached via a short from an
aide seafaring developed in Prioleau in
the 17th century houses that were once
the homes of sea captain's harken back
to those days they've been restored with
typical coloured doors and many feature
a nautical orientation point the Sun as
a distinctive motif the seaman's Church
is located on the outskirts of Prioleau
sailor is once used it's tower to find
their way home in those days the sea
took many lives seafarers graves in the
churchyard tell the stories of entire
families
inside model ships made by sailors hang
above the pews some were crafted by men
who'd been shipwrecked to thank God for
rescuing them from the deep
Crale rule is a good place to start a
venture into the national park dedicated
to preserving a large area of coastal
wetlands known as the for commercial
bottom line shaft many areas of the fish
lenders peninsula are protected cars are
prohibited the only way to explore them
is on foot a bicycle on horseback or in
a horse-drawn cart
Nature has been left to run its course
in the DARS forest in some places the
undergrowth is nearly impenetrable
foresters say the original primeval
growth extends over an area of 50 square
kilometres one popular stop is the
lighthouse in das village one of the
Baltics oldest and a symbol of the
peninsula anyone who climbs that 127
steps to the top will be rewarded with a
view far and wide over forests and dunes
but most people come here to see the
wilds of West Beach one of the area's
main attractions it's been shaped by the
wind and waves meaning its appearance
changes daily
the fish Landis Peninsula is bordered on
one side by the Baltic and on the other
by a large Lagoon or sound known as the
button sandwiched between the sound and
the sea along a narrow strait is Aaron's
hope after a stroll through this
charming seaside town and artists colony
a lookout across the Baltic from the
steep cliffs will really make you
understand the attractions of the
peninsula
my guest is Martin Gallup
singer/songwriter and that's one of his
favorite places
so Jeremy in looking at that I can see
why what do you make of the music scene
here in Jonas I know that's big question
but you've been here for a long time and
you've been playing music all that time
this land is a sort of treasure treasure
chest of culture but doesn't seem to
produce singer-songwriters like yourself
why do you think that is yeah I'd really
sure if that's true Rob and I there's a
lot of German singer songwriters
emerging in the last new 20 years I
think on the international scene on the
audience it's a language thing as well
yeah probably
and I suppose really I mean Germany
suffered a terrible cultural loss from
the second world war you know all of
that all of that creative energy that
they exterminated and and I think to was
so you know the shame that that followed
in the German psyche that made people
feel like all German music is is bad all
that folk music and and what they call
Schlag are sort of the German hit parade
was very frowned upon and so I guess in
a way Germans kind of sort of tightened
up and couldn't you know put out
physically is freely and yeah and a lot
of people just left the country and a
lot of people went into exile exactly
yeah we 1930
so I'm thinking not my hero but the
music I know about bettering Berlin is
once he's not German I beg your pardon
what you wish and people like that or
these classic song hmm
bah with yourself you've been here a
long time you speak fluent German and
you I believe you're thinking of doing
an album in German it's something I've
been toying with for quite a while while
I was working with Udo Lindenberg a lot
of times he wasn't there in the studio
and we would be kind of preparing for
his arrival by getting one of his songs
ready and sometimes somebody had to sort
of sing the song just so we knew where
we were in the song so I was doing that
quite often and the producer later said
you know there's something in that when
you when you sing in German with your
terrible accent that's it's got charm to
it and he kind of got me going on the
idea of doing a German record and I have
dabbled in a bit of writing in German
myself there isn't there is something
online on the iTunes version of my
record that is in German and yeah it
does it come is it more tricky I mean
it's definitely you know I I wouldn't
really want to do that without some help
you know cuz I although I think I have a
really quite good grasp of the German
language a good vocabulary and they can
express myself well I'm not in total
control like one is with with the native
tongue yeah you're very much a
troubadour one can say I'm and they have
a reputation from traveling from town to
town breaking hearts um have you had
your own heart broken
oh absolutely yeah yeah I mean I never
let myself get as heartbroken as I was
by that girl back in public school it's
a huge heartbreak yes same thing you
know yeah you know I must say I love the
subject matter for songs and sometimes I
you know get paranoid and think oh god
that's you know they've got a record
with 14 songs and 8 of them are about
lost love and
but whenever I get worried about that I
return to one of my big songwriting
heroes Hank Williams senior who I think
pretty much didn't write about anything
else than having his heart broken well
you either broke her heart or had your
heart broken by Annette Lewis son who's
a famous singer here and we saw her
briefly in the report at the beginning
but you're producing her now and
obviously I presume mates absolutely I
mean we started off working together and
we've ended up working together and
there was a period in between where we
were romantically involved and very
close and we still are I was you know a
bit of a rough face when we were
separated you know for the first year so
but I'm so so grateful for that
friendship women obviously your muse let
the we want you to sing what hey what's
a better muse I know but I I think this
song most probably this isn't about it
is about a woman in a way there's a
woman called mrs. bowler and she's an
old woman who's I'm sure long passed now
but she's the central figure okay well
you get your you start sort of getting
everything together
yeah and while Martin is getting ready
if you'd like to win his CD signed of
course with his best wishes he hasn't
done that yeah but I'm sure he will he's
a nice guy course droppers an email to
incite DW de and please include your
postal address in case you are the lucky
winner the album is called most
beautiful song and he says the songs get
more beautiful as goes on so this is
track four yes does this Martin mean
that this is only a quite a beautiful
yeah I guess theoretically I mean it
doesn't have to be chronological the
idea is that the songs battle it out
against each other from which one is the
most beautiful and usually by the end of
the record the listener can't decide so
he has to go back and listen to it again
it's over to you yeah a little blues a
little blue store
let's move storm I want to show you
place I used to go to the boulders
little beast or he run up those stairs
getting all my kids open in that old
screen the smell of smoke and candy and
so bad creak of the dusty wood floor me
running up those stairs forgetting all
my cares Mama's little secret
one two three four steps of the old
porch steps and how this is Mona how are
you
five rockets and a box of cherry juice
sweet tart sour grapes all you could ask
for corner could get you yes mom would
let you go to the middle blue
Saint Teresa's schoolyard best be on
your guard especially cross alone
those Catholic kids could kick the crap
out of you good and make you feel very
powerful and down in the ravine they're
touching more easy undying love we would
swim all but something's gone askew now
I'm awfully blue on my way to you know
the four steps the old porch steps and
how long this is morning how are you Bob
Rock incentive back of cherry juice
sweet Johnson sour grapes all you could
ask for corner to get you yes mam little
blue
it's hard now to believe this once was
all trees creeks and fields and farms
till another shopping mall and
subdivision sprawl covered over all it's
gone
oh but this sold by the vine and still
see the Sun fan the blue screen door
just over that hill stand-in there still
boulders little boost
one two three four steps of deal and
hello mr. Hari Farah get set back of
cherry juice
all those bees are gone now
four more mrs. boulders in heaven and
now there's a 7-eleven where one stood a
little blue stone oh mama wanna go to
the ball a little blues
thank you so much thank you was a real
privilege to sit here I think listen I
mean it seems to come so easily to you
but I wonder about writing it always
intrigues me about writing so much
because I can't you probably just
haven't tried hard enough well I do when
I was twelve little older than twelve
actually yes I did I have written I
think many men I don't know women most
probably why I have written a song
because of a lost love or a love or
something but I would never show mine
it's terrible but no it's really really
wonderful but is writing the songs the
most difficult but it's certainly for me
the most rewarding part of it when it's
complete there's a sense of okay this is
it has a life of its own whereas
recording a song is always in a way sort
of making it static you have this
version edged in stone and it's just a
version but it's kind of stuck in there
in time somewhere when you write a song
and it's finished you feel like oh this
I can sing this again and again or even
if I'm really lucky someone else might
sing it it's it's kind of almost like
you know having a child or something it
has a life of its own did you do you do
everything I mean you produce everything
I want to show this picture because this
sums up the recording process it no it
totally does yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
taken by a friend of mine Mikhail young
Blut who's always keen to capture the
real Martin Gallup took the picture on
those very either record it there now we
have a questionnaire I want to ask you a
couple of things about the questionnaire
do you remember what your the best kept
secret in Germany is the best kept
secrets that's probably me it seeks as
modest as I am yeah
but the bet and also I just want to ask
you about two things the best thing
about living in Germany do you remember
what you wrote I don't actually that was
a few months ago now Robin can you help
most of the countries relatively uncuff
you open transparent very affluent
society if you're within its gates and
can eke out even a modest living you're
in pretty good hands yeah yeah there is
that how you feel oh yeah it's so much
to be grateful for I mean I know there
are many people here who who don't have
those kinds of privileges perhaps who
you know having a rough time but for me
and for most people that I see around me
it's it's really in a haven of yeah in
the Rob at me I mean there are people
obviously poorer than as if you like yes
within Germany but the social system
yeah relatively of course eople of [ __ ]
it's not as good as it was when I came
in 1983 back in that day when I couldn't
believe it I mean everybody every
struggling student who'd never seemed to
study anyways you know had their own car
and those were really the good old days
I guess but yeah I do think you remember
who you wrote down as the coolest living
German you've already mentioned that
would have to be uh dodeth Lehrer
Lindenberg who's actually a an artist
who I adored back in my in the 90s when
I was together with a girl from East
Germany and she turned me on to
Lindenberg we used to listen to him all
the time
we should we should explain him a little
bit because he's a megastar year in
Germany he's made over 40 albums in a
career spanning four decades a pioneer
of German rock music and absolutely
quite a character too
in Cologne 18,000 fans of waiting for
the party to get going the star of the
show makes a flying entrance in a
Zeppelin
he clearly has a head for Heights Udo
Lindenberg made this spectacular
entrance 15 times on his last major
concert tour
once lucky come he was incredible the
audience was fantastic so warm so loving
so when I got out of his airplane it was
like they declared their love for me
what Houston I knew the place would
explode I was on fire so were they who's
gonna be a big family celebration Udo
Lindenberg sold out the Cologne Lance s
arena for three nights he sang 28 songs
in each show and was on stage for over
three hours
a German rock legend he's still going
strong
he's quite a character they really is
the impression you know it doesn't seem
to take himself too seriously
that's his genius really actually he and
I hope I've learned something from him
but that he took me aside once and said
Martin you know because I sort of play
the modest modest artist and said you
know modesty Martin is very unattractive
fiction tell them you're the greatest
and you know they'll never really think
you mean it they might either they might
not know and that he's had a musical
written about him which is a huge
success right here in Berlin I know it
Caesar they certainly deserves it I
think he is a genius in the talking
about taking himself seriously I'll
bring this to another thing in the ocean
now where you said you say the Germans
take themselves too seriously did they
say - seriously no - take themselves
seriously though you said this is a
positive thing something the Germans do
really well and you said take things
seriously you remember I do remember
saying that absolutely and I remember
very well feeling that when I came to
Germany because I was in I wasn't happy
in Canada when I was a young man again I
was you know taking the psychedelic
drugs and not drinking alcohol like most
of the people around me at that age and
felt a little bit sort of outcast and it
all seemed terribly superficial to me
the the Canadian mentality at that time
I see that very differently now but when
I came to Germany you know there were
all these these kids dealing with the
whole burden of guilt from the Second
World War and you politically active and
you know just serious and I really liked
that and and friendships were really you
know if somebody said let's have lunch
together they actually meant it whereas
in candidates all we have to do that
lunch thing you know
but it didn't necessarily mean you had
to read the yes who wants you know of
what that actually means in Canada when
someone says let's have lunch together
whether they mean you know see you next
year or say Minh in my home country yeah
and that's one thing I I love here I
mean they're fine they're they're
sincere mmm yeah and they which also can
be you know they'll also say if they
don't like something they're very
forthright I think in that way something
to get used and that can come over as
being blunt and I can come over as being
blunt it's not yeah well yeah or is it
well it is kind of is but is in a sharp
way yeah a final picture to get you
going against your your that your love
your lady and yeah yeah and showing this
picture are you here to stay then is
this is this home now this picture was
taken in Canada well okay I didn't know
that it was snow on the ground
ice skating yes very German as by the
Canadian but you know but well I
certainly home now is this hi Matt it
sure does feel like it certainly here in
Berlin
I feel really really good here right now
but you know it's very subjective we go
through different phases of life I've
got a I've got to stop you there
thank you very much being I guess it's
gone in in a trice hasn't it yeah thanks
very much bath in throwing this be
interested in his album right for as an
insight at DWD thanks for watching until
next week